[Música]
lunes más tenemos ya nuestra Crónica de
salud hoy tenemos con nosotros a nuestra
compañera Natalia plazas Natalia
bienvenida Buenos días Rodrigo Muchas
gracias ya tenemos aquí para hablar del
aniversario de la Organización Mundial
de la Salud que cumple ya 75 años y
vamos a aprovechar para hacer un balance
de sus logros en estas décadas pero
también de los desafíos que todavía
enfrenta cuéntanos Natalia sí Rodrigo
son 75 años ya fue justamente el 7 de
abril de 1948 cuando nació esta entidad
que surgió justamente un par de años
después de que nacieran en 1945 las
Naciones Unidas La idea inicial con la
que se creó la OMS fue justamente estar
un poco desvinculada de la ONU de sus
asuntos políticos y poder concentrarse
un poco más en los asuntos a nivel de
salud justamente para luchar para reunir
esfuerzos para luchar contra
enfermedades y otros retos que
enfrentaba el mundo en ese momento de
salud Ese fue el
cometido inicial y esto fue lo que dijo
el director de la OMS para recordar su
aniversario
Las Naciones del mundo tuvieron una
visión después de años de guerra se
dieron cuenta de que era mejor trabajar
juntos que luchar entre ellos se dieron
cuenta de que un mundo más sano era un
mundo más seguro
la Constitución de la OMS fue el primer
documento de la historia en reconocer
formalmente la salud como un derecho
humano pero hemos escuchado al director
de la OMS Y esta es una fecha que
también sirve Natalia para recordar los
avances que ha habido en las últimas
décadas tanto como en el desarrollo de
medicinas en planes de vacunación
también en cooperación entre países que
podemos destacar de todos estos temas
bueno Rodrigo es un balance muy amplio y
ahí digamos un dato que es crucial para
entender un poco todos estos avances y
es la expectativa bebida que ha crecido
digamos una expectativa global no O sea
que agrupa tanto a hombres como a
mujeres y a distintos países y niveles
socioeconómicos y este índice ha pasado
de ser de 46 años en 1948 a 73 años en
la actualidad pero repasemos también
otros de los principales avances que ha
habido en estos años en 1980 la OMS dio
la noticia de que se había erradicado la
viruela una enfermedad que solamente en
el siglo XX debemos recordar llegó a
matar hasta 300 millones de personas
luego también está como vemos en este
gráfico los avances contra la
poliomielitis recordemos que esta
enfermedad afectó a decenas de miles de
niños durante todo el siglo XX y que
pudo ser erradicada bueno No erradicada
justamente en los que se está trabajando
pero que ha podido llegar a ser
prácticamente radicada en un 99% gracias
a titánicas campañas de vacunación
recordemos también Rodrigo que
actualmente hay preocupa respecto a esta
enfermedad debido a que sean encontrado
brotes recientemente en distintas partes
del mundo por otro lado la OMS también
resalta a
resalta El Avance que ha habido en la
lucha contra la malaria que ha sido
eliminada ya en 42 países sin embargo
Rodrigo también hace falta recordar que
justamente la respuesta a esta
enfermedad ha sido una de las más
criticadas
[Música]
para la OMS porque justamente esta
campaña fue una de las más costosas en
toda la historia de la entidad y que sin
embargo a lo largo de décadas no ha
logrado erradicarla otras citas que
también se resaltan y que se han
conseguido los últimos años ha sido
eliminar las epidemias del VIH y de la
tuberculosis y también más recientemente
resaltemos también la lucha de la
entidad Para coordinar todos los
esfuerzos en contra del covid 19 esta
que ha sido justamente la emergencia
sanitaria más grande que hemos vivido en
más de un siglo desde luego un gran un
gran reto para la MS pero para todos
nosotros también Natalia vamos a hablar
ahora de lo que le espera a la MS hemos
hablado de todo lo que se ha hecho hasta
ahora pero Cuáles son los principales
retos que enfrenta tanto esta entidad
como todo el planeta bueno Rodrigo Pues
arrancamos con datos son 8,6 millones de
personas los que fallecen cada año
debido a la falta de una cobertura
sanitaria adecuada pero también podemos
repasar otros de los principales
desafíos que enfrentan tanto la OMS como
todos los gobiernos del mundo
actualmente las enfermedades no
transmisibles son las causantes del 70%
de las muertes a nivel mundial
recordemos que estas enfermedades son
las enfermedades que no son causadas por
una infección pero que sin embargo pues
conllevan por ejemplo cánceres
enfermedades cardiovasculares
enfermedades pulmonares pero también
están las enfermedades mentales dentro
de todas estas enfermedades no
transmisibles esto se agrava también en
los últimos años debido a que ha habido
un aumento en las tasas de dia y de
obesidad
causadas estos aumentos mucho por
nuestra vida sedentaria y también por
una falta de alimentación adecuada
también
influyen muchísimo en los desafíos que
tenemos por delante la contaminación del
aire y el cambio climático pues tanto
grandes fenómenos como sequías o olas de
calor están causando
estragos en la vida de millones de
personas y tenemos que tener en cuenta
también las futuras pandemias
por el hecho Pues de que ya evidenciamos
con la pandemia de Kobe 19 de que hay
muchos desafíos hay brechas muy grandes
que cerrar por ejemplo con el tema de
las vacunas cuando hubo tanto
acaparamiento de las vacunas en esta
pandemia que estamos todavía superando
para terminar hacemos un resumen también
de las recomendaciones que da la OMS
para los próximos años la entidad Llama
a
esta cooperación multilateral también a
reforzar en materia de investigación a
fortalecer los sistemas sanitarios y a
formar más personal en salud y esto es
muy importante Rodrigo porque
digamos que hay un dato que es
importante retener y es que la OMS
estima que para 2030 habrá un déficit de
18 millones de trabajadores en salud es
importante porque porque si no tenemos
trabajadores de salud tampoco vamos a
tener aquí en la tienda a2 millones de
personas que hay en los distintas
regiones del mundo y como bien nos
acabas de explicar los retos son enormes
de aquí a 2030 y más adelante Natalia
Muchas gracias por este repaso de salud
Te veremos mucho más a menudo de aquí en
adelante también Muchas gracias gracias
Rodrigo